millions of people in Southern
California face an extreme red flag
warning about fire conditions for the
first time ever this is a big deal a
fire that disrupted force new
evacuations in Simi Valley that's near
the Reagan Presidential Library crews in
Northern California battling the massive
Kincaid fire are facing heavy when that
fire is damaged or destroyed about 200
homes and other buildings in the area
the Kincaid fire is one of about a dozen
wildfires burning throughout California
Santa Ana winds in Southern California
could gust to 80 miles an hour about one
and a half million people statewide are
without power as utilities try to
prevent new fires Jonathan Vigliotti is
in Healdsburg California where signs of
the fire are seen everywhere Jonathan
good morning good morning to you Anthony
and unfortunately this has become the
new normal scenes like this this is
actually what's left of a vineyard that
was destroyed by the fire on Sunday the
concern was high winds overnight would
further destroy at more buildings the
gusts reaching about 60 miles per hour
they have calmed down a bit at this hour
there are still thousands of
firefighters working 24-hour shifts to
put out those hotspots all of this as
thousands of people remain in shelters
some for the third night in a row as the
Kinkaid fire continued to grow with no
new containment in sight flames late
Tuesday were visible from San Francisco
some 70 miles away we can confirm 189
structures have now been destroyed 86 of
those are single-family dwellings and
his high winds threatened to widen the
fires reach Coleen Murray and her young
children spent another night as a
vacuous for the second time in two years
been out of the house and Saturday so
it's been a little rough in the van with
all the kids it's kind of cold that
night but other than that it's good
she's one of more than 150 thousand
people displaced by the Kincaid fire
many streaming into shelters unsure when
they can go home Jill champion evacuated
with her three dogs do you worry this is
the new
for you yeah actually a thing I'm
thinking you know is this what we're
gonna go through every summer now it's
scary when you know it seems like one is
worse than the one behind it but
California governor Gavin Newsom tells
CBS this morning this scenario cannot be
the new normal
200,000 people at peak were evacuated
seniors with deep medical conditions
need of oxygen and medications that they
weren't able to source this is serious
scope and serious scale the area's
nearly 2.2 billion dollar tourism
industry is also feeling an impact towns
in wine country are now empty during the
height of this season you're talking
about tens if not hundreds of millions
of dollars of loss so if we don't have
people show up we don't have any income
to pay for our staff and we talk about
the new normal think about this 3,000
people we are told remain in 20 sell
ters tonight officials asking for their
continued patience they say the
evacuations won't be lifted until they
get a better handle an idea of where
this fire is going it could take another
week Tony before it is fully contained
thinking about those people in shelters
in the 86 single-family homes no homes
to go back to Jonathan thank you very
much